today we're talking about eldon ring
legend let me solo her getting a very
special gift a gta 5 modder getting a
takedown notice and more
elden rings most famous cooperative
player let me solo her was gifted a
massive box set from bandai namco and
from software that included a sword over
on twitter let me solo her posted
pictures of the box set alongside a
thank you note from bandai namco the
elden ring team and the soulsborne
community the box itself features a
wooden sculpted portrait of millennia a
note from bandai namco featuring an
adorable sketch of let me solo her's
in-game character and a sword with the
text rise tarnished on the blade let me
solo her rose to prominence by fighting
millennia one of the toughest bosses in
elden ring for players who were having a
hard time the name let me solo her
encouraged other players to stay back
and let him do the work armed with
nothing but a katana and a pot helmet
let me solo her would dominate millennia
with almost scientific precision
assisting hundreds of players in
vanquishing the now infamous boss what a
cool way to honor the true elden lord
and now let's talk about a company
sending someone something not so
pleasant rockstar's parent company take
2 has reportedly issued a dmca takedown
against modder luke ross known for
making vr mods for games like gta 5 and
red dead redemption 2. luke ross shared
a post on patreon detailing the notice
that read quote they are demanding that
i remove all copyright works from my
patreon page i immediately ask for
clarification since it's my belief that
i'm not hosting any such materials luke
ross notes that they have no experience
with dmca notices so isn't entirely
certain if they will actually receive a
clarification on where the issues lie or
not in a later update to the post luke
ross said that they still had not heard
back from take two but patreon itself
offered to try and quote establish a
direct channel luke ross's real mod for
grand theft auto 5 which adds vr to the
game is available to download from
github but lugross's mods for red dead
redemption 2 and the mafia trilogy
another take-two product are still in
development and in a bit of unrelated
news e3 has made another announcement
about its return and this time read pop
is running the show read pop which also
runs pax star wars celebration and
several other shows will work in
partnership with the entertainment
software association to host publishers
developers journalists and consumers at
e3's usual location the la convention
center for e3 2023 read pop says that it
has listened to feedback from the gaming
community will honor the e3 elements
that have always worked and will reshape
the parts that haven't been well
received e3 2020 was cancelled due to
the pandemic while e3 2021 returned as a
digital only event and e3 2022 was
completely cancelled a streamlined and
secure media registration for e3 2023
will begin in late 2022 while a list of
confirmed exhibitors and event schedules
will be shared in the months to come and
finally after years of development and
multiple delays ubisoft's pirate game
skull bones has a release date of
november 8th the day before god wore
ragnarok and i know the games are
nowhere near the same so i'm not saying
that skull bones is going to fail
because everyone's buying god of war but
you can't deny that it's definitely
going to be overshadowed that release
week and probably
like a week or two afterwards
however if you want more information on
living a pirate's life you can check out
the gameplay overview trailer or the
full presentation that ubisoft held for
skull bones on our youtube channel right
now there's also a written preview up
from jordan remay on site that i'll link
below
you